yeah you guys tell me exactly what you
want to do when I tell you how to
resolve it what this game is I'm like
the type of nerd who grew up writing
fanfiction and like I had other nerd
friends who played this and I was like
maybe that's not my thing
the image is like of like sweaty dudes
in a basement which is like not always
the most fun place to be you guys are
part of an adventuring band some of you
are out see the world so you are out to
spend your faith others are out for gold
what are the interests interests are you
guys are working together so you want to
spread the word of cthulhu I would like
that yes okay give me a little Jewish
exporting so you could come over to them
and how do you present yourself to this
woman oh that would be that would be the
mayor Lord Faris you to see an
inscription on the door and a placard it
says what runs around the city but never
moves a door slam shut fences don't run
when they do it runs around the city
does I move a wall immediately the door
in front of you oh yeah you guys picked
it you down in the hallway now in each
of the cuts is a child
the girls were great they jumped right
into it they weren't afraid to take
risks I'll shake your hand but the deal
is that we there's nothing more to this
deal other than taking the parchment to
ordinary you vote that we killed the
demon let's kill it even it actually was
a lot easier than I thought I was gonna
be I honestly thought it was gonna be
like too hard and like to dry and like
not easy to follow and like that was not
the case at all it wasn't that scary
even though we were in a cave girls Andy
Andy they've always gone together just
fine I don't know you know why there's a
stigma I actually kept my character she
I can totally see myself playing this
again
[Music]
[Music]